صباح الخير طبعا انا اطلع عليكم اليوم من
الخان الذي يعد نقطه فاصله بين مدينه
الفلوجه ومحافظات بغداد ويقعل خان الى
الغرب من العاصمه بغداد هذا الخام اسس في
نهايه الدوله العثمانيه في نهايه عصر
الدوله العثمانيه على يد الشيخ ضاري
المحمود وهو احد شيوخ عشائر زوبع في
العراق طبعا هذا الخام كان ملتقى للقبائل
والعشائر التي تسافر من الحجاز الى بلاد
الشام ومحطه استراحه لهم ولهذا الخان
حكايه مهمه اذا انطلقت اولى شراره شراره
الثوره العشرين من هذا الخان وبعد مقتل
الجنرال الامريكي البريطاني ليش مان على
يد الشيخ ضاري المحمود واولاده في هذا
الخان بعد هذا همم انطلقت شراره الثوره
طبعا هذا الخان اهمل في عام 2003
اعيد تاهيله في الذكرى الثانيه بعد المائه
الثوره ومعي اليوم مدير الخان وهو الاستاذ
ايوب الزوبعي الذي سيتحدث لنا عن كيف اهمل
الخان وكيف اعيد تاهيله صباح الخير
نحب تحدثنا كيف هم الخان وكيف اعيد
التاهيله الخام همم طلعت عليه عده عمليات
الترميم بدايه سنه سنه 1983 همم ثم سنه
1999 وصول الى سنه 2022 على يد حفيد الشيخ
طارق الشيخ جمال الظاهري عن طريق مؤسسه
تابعه لهم مؤسسه الظاهره للتنميه والتطوير
ممكن تتحدثن عن مساحه الخان شنو الغرف
اللي همم يتضمنها الخان وايضا شنو
المقتنعات الموجوده اليوم في الخان طبعا
مساحه الخان تبلغ 3000 و300 متر مربع همم
يحتوي الخائن على بوابه رئيسيه يضم تسعه
غرف وهمم ساحه اروح بقى كبيره تتوسط الخام
ومضيف لا يقل طوله عن 36 متر همم يحيط
بهذا ال- خان همم
يبلغ ارتفاعه وهو مترين ونصف سمكه واحد
ويحتوى الخائن على مكتبه الان مكتبه علميه
في يضم عدد من المصادر المهمه النادره في
مختلف المجالات ويضم متحف تراثي اثري همم
يحتوي على مقتنيات همم عسكريه
ساهمت في ثوره ال 20
ل زعماء ثوره ال20 وعدد من الشيوخ القبائل
في ذلك الوقت نحب نعرف كيف وصلتكم هذه
الصور الصور وصلت لنا عن طريق احفاد
قاده ثوره ال 20 همم رسام جبنا الصور في
رسمها طبق الاصل
صوره لها حكايه يعني في الخان اللي هيظهر
بها زعماء ثوره ال 20 كيف وصلت لكم هاي
الصوره هاي داخل سجن الكوفه كانت
عندنا من همم بعض الشخصيات الحلوه
تيجنال همم الحله يعني ادخل الكاميرا داخل
السجن العائد له شخصيا هائل من ممتلكاته
الشخصيه
صافي من الشارع اليوم تختلف عن القصصه
اللي نتحدث عنها من الشارع العراقي كون
شخصيه القصه غير موجوده لكن هي خالده
خالده بفعلها وخالده بما قدمته للعراق من
يعني من منجز خاصه ان ثوره العشرين احدث
ثورات المهمه في العراق واللي من خلالها
استطاع العراق ان يعلن دوله مستقله في
التاريخ الحديث يعني سهام مناديل وايضا
همم انا اليوم ارتدي زي ال- همم
القبلي او زي العشاء في ذلك الوقت اللي
يتضمن الاعضاء اللي احنا بنسميها الدشداشه
والشالهاعتكم سؤال ايضا للضيف همم نسمع
سؤالكم منوره يا زينب
زينب فعلا ام تعطينا وذهبنا معكم الى حقبه
تاريخيه غنيه في المعلومات ومرتبطه بثقافه
ثقافه عراقيه شكرا جزيلا لك زينب ودائما
بتعيشي المكان من حيث اللباس يعني هذا
اكثر من لوك لزينه في كذا مرحله